[Music]
Cody is with us in Savannah Georgia hi
Cody how are you hey I'm doing well Dave
are you better than I deserve what's up
it's got a question about buying a house
versus raining first up let's say
whenever we started this program about
halfway through our buying house buying
experience and we have about $37,000 and
move that we really didn't even know it
was that until we started in the program
and doing a budget we I guess the
question is is should we stop our house
buying now or should we finish ring or
Steiner and it stopped your house buying
what does that mean you you are you like
we're going to convert we were we were
under contract where are we we were
under contract and we I cancelled the
dance on the deal okay
and you're under contract now No
okay I'm not no you cannot buy a house
okay you know thirty seven thousand
dollars in debt you're broke
yes sir and when brought about houses it
makes them broker oh yeah I know I guess
my other question was I guess I with
interest rates I guess interest rates
are going up substantial incoming that
has since in since the beginning of the
process and now it's going to break a
bit Cody I guess there's nothing to
worry about later on I got my real
estate license in 1978 in September in
October rates went from nine and
three-quarters to ten for the first time
ever
yeah people bought houses rates are for
when they go to five people will buy
houses when they go to six people will
buy houses it's not gonna keep you from
buying a house yeah no I guess it's just
you always hear about the hire industry
oh you're gonna hear your pants can jump
up so much yeah you know you hear about
that from people who don't know how her
on a calculator and who are broke yeah
usually a real estate agent trying to
sell you a house - yeah it's kind of
exactly what I'm talking about yeah how
old are you 25 okay here's the thing
this show is about creating a situation
with your money where your money doesn't
own you you own your money where you
move towards wealth and the shortest
path possible that's what this shows
about financial peace - words that don't
go together like airline service okay
that's what this shows about it's not
about you keeping up with the Joneses
the Joneses are broke if you even know
who they are these people that post crap
on Instagram and they post crap on
Facebook they only put the good parts of
their life on there it's there highlight
reel dude it's not real you can't
compare yourself to them the vast
majority of people are broke 70% of
Americans live paycheck to paycheck 7
out of 10 people you walk past going
down the sidewalk are broke you can
model your life after them and you will
be one of them yeah or you can model
your life after the weird people because
wealth is unusual it's not normal and so
you have to engage in unusual behaviors
and habits to create unusual results
agreed all right it's not normal to win
the Super Bowl the people that win the
Super Bowl are admired because they did
something other people couldn't do or
wouldn't do they paid a price okay
yes there so when you are 65 or 70 years
old and you're a multi-millionaire
because of this conversation you will be
yelling 'yay way to go 25 year-old Cody
yeah if you go do smart stuff so here's
what I'm going to tell you that I want
you to get a house
I just don't want your house to get you
don't panic don't panic you're 25 and
I'm sorry go ahead you're gonna get a
house you're gonna get a house and
there's no there's no mathematical
justification for you buying a house no
interest rate justification for you
buying a house while you have thirty
seven thousand dollars in debt you clean
up your data and you get out of debt if
you move into a house with this much
debt and no money
Murphy is gonna move in your spare
bedroom the guy if it says if it can go
wrong it will he'll bring his three
cousins broke desperate and stupid and
they'll set up housekeeping will you
dude your house your life will look like
a country song this house will be a
curse instead of a blessing I want it to
be a blessing so here's the option you
move in now like all your friends are
doing and all these idiots that are
broke that are pressuring you to buy a
house right now when you're when you're
broke 25 year old young married guy and
you're gonna make a mess it's gonna take
you a decade to clean this mess up if
you do this or you can be weird you can
roll up your sleeves and you can become
debt-free very very quickly and I'll
show you how and you can save up a good
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and I'll show you how and then
you can save up a good down payment
it's gonna delay your home buying by a
couple of years but when you move in the
house with $20,000 cash in the bank and
no payments the house is a blessing not
a curse when you move in the house right
now
the way you set up right now it's gonna
be it's gonna be more stress how long
you been married we've been together
we've been married about a year and a
half and we have a she's going on eight
months old now that's wonderful
number one number one calls a divorce in
North America today money fights and
stress oh yeah that's where our mean
that's the only thing that mean wife
really ever argue about yeah and uh no I
mean I have a guy have a great job
what's your household income
well my base buy it my base pay is
around seventy seven thousand dollars
which our old income Cody anywhere but
well I made a hundred and ten last year
but I'm on the track now for like 130
and it's all because of overtime I work
70 hours a week your money making
machine do
and yeah does your wife work outside the
home no that's the thing is I want to
hurt it's where she does her work
that's fine she doesn't you she doesn't
you make 130 sohow class house can you
pay off 37,000 making 130 my
calculations say a year yeah my plan was
to try and get it done within a year by
didn't I I guess I get stuck in and do I
buy a house now you know he's you know
that's the thing you have to do so I've
been talking to you for five minutes
trying to get you on staff I want you
unstuck okay because you make really
good money you have the opportunity to
clean this debt up and build your
emergency fund to three to six months of
expenses and then save your down payment
and buy the house on a 15 year fixed
where the height where the payments no
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay
you're gonna get that house paid off in
about seven or eight years but the time
you're 35 you're gonna have a paid for
home and a couple hundred thousand
dollars in your 401k by the time you're
40 you're gonna be a millionaire or
sooner the way you're going if you do
what I teach you to do but if you go but
a normal and you strap yourself to a
house you can't afford and you keep that
debt around like it's a bad gum pet
you're gonna be normal and you're gonna
be a rat no for you and all your money's
gonna come in and all your money's gonna
go out and you have no frickin idea
where it goes and you're gonna be a
broke 40 year old that's worked two
decades of his life looking at your kids
can't figure out how you're gonna pay
for vacation and Christmas and that's
normal out there man you know it's
normal you know what I'm telling you is
right and all these broke people have
opinions about money that's like I made
a mistake of budgeting I mean on every
timing I didn't have an issue yeah yeah
I knew in the mistake of budgeting on
parson my overtime because which means
you have to never mean it that means you
have to work overtime the rest of your
life yeah I don't have to do that yeah
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
work like no one else right now so later
we can work like no one else which is
not why I would if I got what I want to
so have you and your wife been through
Financial Peace University yet yeah we
are finishing it right now the actual
steps right now we're doing the program
right now I'm sorry did you go to the
class did you go to the Windows No
we're doing it on our own you're doing
it online yes sir you're signed up for
Financial Peace University online
correct yeah okay good Wow I would join
a group in your area if I were you and
go to some of the lessons with a group
and get some other people around you
that are walking the same path you're
walking because you need some people
around you they aren't normal right now
you got broke people on your ear you
gotta get them out of your ear you
become who you hang around with man be
careful hey it's good to talk to you
Cody if I converted you I just made you
a millionaire if I didn't
you'll be normal it'll be up to you my
son this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]